that's what life looks like through
spectacles the new product from the
company formerly known as snapchat now
they're just called snap I don't feel
now for 130 bucks sort of see the only
way to get a pair is to find one of the
mysterious snap bot vending machines
that or prepare to pay a lot of money
for some secondhand these cost me 600
bucks so how are they well there are a
lot more socially acceptable than Google
glass and about 1/16 is useful
they make videos and not much else but
there's a simple Beauty to that and snap
does have a real knack for figuring out
where we're going with cameras and this
is a big one you don't look like a tool
wearing them well you don't look like
much of a tool here's how spectacles
work there are lenses on both stems they
combine the shoot video with 115 degree
field view you press the button by your
left temple and the glasses capture 10
seconds of a UI view in a cool circular
format that you're set friends can spin
their phone around to see it all sinks
to a new specs folder in your snapchat
app where you can edit and share just
like any other snap the video they shoot
is it's fun it's not great it's not even
as good as your phone camera but it
looks okay in snapchat the really cool
part is just how it makes you rethink
the way you capture the world and
literally the way you see it because the
way that you look for the spectacles
look it just feels effortless to you
just tap on the button and look around
you get to be in the moment while
inviting your friends to be there too
it's a really nice break from seeing the
world through a smartphone screen
I don't want to get high-minded and
nostalgic here these things are
basically toys right now just toys with
a totally genius marketing plan but Snap
is really good at figuring out how
people want to communicate and this
feels like part of that you're just
sharing a moment with somebody else and
that might make these the first wearable
cameras people actually don't know where
that is if you can get your hands on